I'm Bill Chapman and I'm a Scoutmaster with Troop 736 in Rancho Santa Margarita, California.
This edition of the Scoutmaster podcast is sponsored by backers like us.
Thanks, Clark, for everything you do.
And now for you Scoutmaster.
Hey, let's talk about trail mix for a moment.
This is a ziplock bag of stuff that you make and you carry along when you go backpacking
or hiking, or maybe you make some up just to go camping.
I have found that there are two basic ingredients to trail mix.
There are M&M's and disappointment.
Do you know exactly what I'm talking about?
Hey, this is podcast number 245..
Hey,
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look in the mailbag.
I'm Donald Fowler, and Don said it's been five months since I've become Scoutmaster.
I'm having a blast.
Our patrol leaders council is taking on more responsibility each month.
My next challenge, of course, is getting the adult leaders to stay away from the Scouts during campouts.
Well, Don, first, I am really happy to hear you're having a blast.
It is the best job going, isn't it?
Being a Scoutmaster. I love it.
And there are challenges, and that's a very common challenge.
If you get there, you're going to get those adults right on board
and things are going to keep getting better.
That's my prediction.
How about that?
Don went on to say.
I recently heard about a troop with over 100 Scouts with some unusual practices.
They will not allow a Scout to advance more than one rank per year
because they feel that Scouts who reach Eagle any younger than age 17 aren't mature enough.
They look down on any Scout who earned Eagle at a younger age.
I did mention to them that this goes against the Guide to Advancement
And the answer I got back was: well, that's how we've always done things
And since we have the biggest troop in the area, it proves that we're right.
Well, Don, of course it's pretty much a no-brainer, isn't it?
The policies you described that this troop has adopted
are specifically prohibited in the Guide to Advancement.
It's right there in black and white.
It's not hard to figure that one out.
What I think is stunning is that people who are expected to model
the virtues of loyalty and obedience to young people
can decide that they're a rule to themselves.
Beyond that, they're convinced that they follow a higher and better rule
than the rest of us poor brunited souls out here. you know,
I mean the hypocrisy in that would be comedic if it was not so tragic.
I will say what I have often said: there's one way to become an Eagle Scout,
and that's completing the requirements as written.
There's nothing about your age in those requirements is there?
If it was written, I could understand it, but it's not there.
Adding to the requirements in the way that this troop has done
is just as misguided as detracting from the requirements.
Unfortunately, though you know, this is not the first troop
I've ever heard of that does things this way.
I've known troops in my own council like this that have set up
their own higher standard of what an Eagle Scout ought to be,
and they are usually insufferably proud of themselves,
But, like the Emperor with no clothes,
they fail to understand that their naked disloyalty
and disobedience is plainly visible
and, honestly, I'm just plain embarrassed for them.
Dave Simmons got in touch with us and he said:
I love the blog and the podcast,
Just wondering why there's only 12 episodes of the podcast on iTunes.
I brought the Scoutmaster CG app to get the rest of the podcast,
but I can't really find a way to download the files to my iPhone,
so I can just listen to them when I'm ready
instead of trying to stream them through the app.
So, Dave, first of all, of course, thank you for your kind words.
It's always great to hear that people enjoy the podcast
and that they actually want to go and listen to all the back issues
in the archive.
I emailed Dave some simple directions on how to get the MP3 files,
get them on his iPhone so that he can listen to them whenever he wants.
If you go to scoutmastercgcom, right at the top of the page,
there's a menu, click on podcast
and then you can get to the archive
and there's instructions exactly on how to do that.
It's a little bit of a workaround when you're dealing with an iPhone
and you know it's the best solution that I have so far.
If you've come up with something better, let me know.
Kelly wrote into and also said
I am working my way through the podcast archives.
Thanks for creating this great resource.
I'm learning a lot by listening and reading scoutmastercgcom.
Thanks so much for getting in touch, Kelly.
I really do appreciate it.
This past week I spent some time chatting with folks
live at scoutmastercgcom.
Keep an eye on the Facebook feed and our Twitter feed
and I will always announce when the live chat is turned on
at scoutmastercgcom.
If you can join us, stop on in
And we just chat.
This week I talked with Doi Shipman,
who is in Okmulgi, Oklahoma, with Troop 102,
where he's the advancement coordinator.
Rob Kerrigan checked in from Portland, Maine,
John Nelson from Westchester, Ohio,
where he's an assistant scout master with Troop 947,
and Dave Smiley from Troop 55
in Santa Rosa, California.
and Steve Carell with PAC 3623 in Shepherd, Michigan-
All checked in.
B Jody Lotzkar is with the 5th West Vancouver
Mountaineer Scouts.
He's a group commissioner and scoutmaster with them
and they're in Vancouver, Canada.
Rhonda Woff-Weinman checked in with us.
Rhonda comes from the Heart of America Council
and was a scoutmaster for almost 12 years
and is now the district membership chair.
And Jim Gilligly checked in to chat
from Mansfield, Massachusetts.
So once again, keep an eye on the Facebook feed
and the Twitter feed.
I'll announce when the chat feature
at ScoutmasterCGcom is live
and stop in and join us
Over on the blog. this week, let's see,
We published two chapters in the story
of a new scoutmaster
and I know a lot of you have been following that
And there were some great comments. this week
James Stonehouse commented.
as a troop scouter and a high school auto teacher,
I always run into leaders and parents
who do the work for youth because it's easier that way.
I deal with a lot of learned helplessness
where mom and dad always did it for me.
so why should I do it?
It's a common situation I run to as a teacher
and a scouter.
I always remind myself I'm not the troop leader.
My patrol leaders are
Myself and the other scouters in the troop
are valuable resources for the troop,
but the youth leaders are the leaders.
Unless it's an immediate safety issue,
the information instruction ought to be coming
from the patrol leader.
If a scout forgets something or breaks something
or loses something,
well they should go to their patrol leader for help.
Being prepared doesn't prevent disasters from happening,
but it helps you survive and learn from it.
Sometimes we need a couple of small disasters
to help us see the need for being prepared.
James, thanks so much for that comment.
It got me thinking about
scouting as a succession of
big challenges and small disasters.
Jim Hillier also checked in on that post.
He says it does seem like our hero,
who's the new scout master in the story,
could have used a more collaborative approach
with the adult in this chapter.
He's doing a great job bringing boys along
with his Socratic approach,
but he's kind of bullying
the vested adult leaders along the way.
And you know, Jim, those are very good thoughts.
Our hero ran into some resistance
in one of the chapters this week
and the whole story isn't told yet.
We need to see how things go from there.
I would say you know,
and I can get where you would get the impression
that he's kind of bullying his fellow adults,
but I think if you look a little bit closer
he's really leading them.
I've only alluded to some of the longer conversations
he's having with his fellow scouts.
I haven't detailed those conversations
because what happens in the rest of the story
is he talks with the scouts.
That's where you get the details
of what he discussed with the other adults.
And in the chapter that you commented on
I did imagine that he explains things a lot more
and you know I went back and looked at it
and I did a little edit where I made that a little clearer.
So I really appreciate those thoughts, Jim.
Dustin Tardidi wrote in on that same chapter.
a volunteer who insists on doing things their own way
is not really helping things out
in an organization like Scout.
Yeah, it takes a lot of collaboration,
It takes a lot of talking
And in the story you have to kind of read in
those longer discussions that I talked about
and also posted an answer to lots of questions
I got from one reader about scouting and money,
And collaborating with me on that post
was Frank Maynard from Bob White Blather,
And Frank has a lot of experience as a committee chair
And if you're a listener to the podcast
you're probably familiar with Frank by now
And his blog is Bob White Blather
And I'll include a link to that blog.
but it's something definitely you want to check out
And you definitely want to check out the comments
on that post.
We heard from Scout Master Phil and B McWilliams.
Julie checked in and one of the comments she made
was that she wishes there was a little more training
for troop or unit treasurers.
John Weidke commented:
thanks for addressing a common topic
that doesn't get a lot of discussion sometimes.
And we also heard from Terry Dutton
on that post and Mike Cathers
And everyone was generously shared
what their troop does when it comes to scouting and money.
And so you definitely want to check out
that post and the comment stream
And it's at ScoutMasterCGcom.
Look for the post on Scouts and Money.
Hey, if you're a regular reader and a listener
and if the resources we've created have helped you.
you can return the favor by becoming a ScoutMasterCGcom backer.
The funds we get from backers go towards the expenses
of producing and publishing the blog
and the podcast, and you know the videos
and all the other resources that we can keep accessible
to scouters all over the world.
It's pretty easy to do: Go to ScoutsMasterCGcom,
Click the support link at the top of the page
and you can choose any level of support.
Some of them are tied to your premiums,
like the autographed copies of my books,
And I'd like to take a moment and personally thank Jim Hu
and Ed Milius, who became backers since our last podcast.
Thanks so very much.
It means a great deal and it keeps us afloat.
So go to ScoutsMasterCGcom and become a backer this week
and I'll make sure to thank you on next week's podcast.
And in this week's podcast
we're going to be answering some email questions
and that's going to take up the remainder of the podcast.
So let's get started, shall we
Email, that is, folks,
And here's an answer to one of your emails.
On a reasonably regular basis,
I get a comment or an email that tells this story.
We're new to town and we asked for a referral
to a boy-led outdoor active troupe
And we got a referral but found that the troupe that we selected
has elections for youth leadership.
but that's about where it stops.
There's usually 20 minutes of adult announcements
at the beginning of each troupe meeting.
Three quarters of the meetings are dedicated
to adult-led merit badge sessions
and the outings are organized entirely by adults.
What I want to know is how can I help change this?
How somebody helps change the way that a troupe functions
is a pretty common question,
And the most direct, simple answer I have for you
is that there are three roles organizationally
within a scout troupe that are empowered to make changes.
That's the chartered organization representative,
the troupe committee chairman
and, to a lesser extent, the scout master.
They're the only people who have the organizational role
that empowers them to make changes like you would like to see.
Can someone who's not occupying one of those roles
help make changes to the way that a troupe functions?
Well, you know, naturally, that all depends
on how receptive the people in those roles are
to change and suggestion,
And I will tell you that, unfortunately, in my experience,
about eight or nine out of ten times they're not interested
And pressing these ideas becomes onerous to them
and subsequently you are identified as a troublemaker.
So where do we go from here?
Well, your scout's interests individually
is the most important factor in determining your way forward. okay,
Let's not kid ourselves, folks.
Many, many troops are administered just as described
and scouts get something out of being a part of them.
They get something out of scouting in that experience.
That's undeniable.
So if your scout is happy,
if he's built a lot of friendships within the troupe
and you make your suggestions
or you share your ideas with how things ought to change
and those are rejected,
then I would say, in the interest of your scout
and because he's built up friendships in the troupe,
he's getting something out of the program,
just leave well enough alone.
Now, if your scout is dissatisfied
with the way things are going
or you as a parent, weigh the importance
of having him participate in a troupe
that uses the patrol system,
if you weigh that very heavily,
then you're going to need to find another troupe.
You know, I know that that's not what most people want to hear,
but it's actually that simple.
There's lots of stories of adults
who try to encourage change in an unwilling troupe
and if they keep pressing things
or they try and make an issue out of it,
it all ends up with a lot of hard feelings.
So I would strongly suggest
you find a troupe that is more suited
to what you want for your scout.
If you aren't in a role to make the changes
like I described before,
there's really no other viable solution.
Now the next concern that is usually raised
when I have these discussions with people
is: how can I in good conscience
abandon the other scouts you know
to this troupe that doesn't get it
and who's running a program?
that's not the patrol system
and it's not what Clark talks about.
Now, if you decide that your family
is going to change troops
and other parents ask you why,
well then you can share the reasons with them
and maybe they will decide
to make a similar change.
If enough of them do this,
folks in the troupe that you left
may get the message.
Unfortunately they may not.
Let's remember what's important here.
The interest of your scout is important.
If he's happy, satisfied,
if he's got a lot of friendships in the troupe
and everything like that,
I would strongly urge you
that if your ideas and suggestions are rejected,
that you just leave well enough alone,
because it's in his best interest.
If he's dissatisfied
and he's ready to make a change,
get it done.
It's a really difficult situation.
It's a very common situation
but it's very, very difficult
and I hope that advice helps.
Heard from Jeff Crump,
who is the scout master
of troupe 701 in Wakefield, Massachusetts.
He said in September
I was chosen as the newest scout master
of our troupe.
I love your podcast and blog
and you can help me immensely
as I've been trying to figure all this out.
We're all still trying to figure it all out,
Doesn't matter how long we've been around, Jeff.
My question revolves around
how much should a scout master
be involved with Eagle paperwork?
I had a great scout master conference
with an Eagle candidate recently,
but when he submitted his paperwork
the essay was returned to him
by our council as being insufficient.
Some folks were upset with me
because I didn't proofread the essay
or review the application
during the scout master conference
and they implied that part of the scout master's job
is to make sure that all the eyes are dotted
and the T's are crossed.
My feeling is, if the scout
wanted any help with his essay,
he could have asked me,
and that the scout master conference
is really not the place to review paperwork.
We have Eagle mentors that help
scouts navigate the whole process.
As I said, in the recent past
some of these adults have been pulling scouts
over the finish line a little too aggressively.
What do you think the proper level
of involvement is for the scout master
and Eagle mentors?
Well, first off, Jeff, I noticed that you became a backer
and I wanted to say thank you so much for that.
and I'm always heartened to hear
I'm providing some assistance
to my fellow scouters out there.
and you know I'll tell you
that being a scout master is great fun,
Even though we run into problems
like this now and again.
but for the most part, you know, it's a great job.
and in my experience
there's no more kind of overblown, overmanaged
cause of problems
that scout masters encounter
than all of this kind of
weirdness and frustration surrounding
Eagle Scout.
It has
kind of the highest freak out factor
of anything else in scouting
as far as my experience goes.
First, to clear up a couple of
terminology things,
and let's just clear that up real quick:
There's no essay required for Eagle.
there's a statement of
ambitions and life purpose that accompanies the application
and
we have project coaches.
we don't have Eagle mentors.
really, The Eagle mentor thing
is a pin
that an Eagle Scout can present
to someone who
he considers has been influential
in helping him reach his goal.
My simple answer to your question-
what is your proper level
involvement and the proper level
involvement for project coaches-
is easy
because I would answer
as little as possible
and, most of the time, only when
the candidate requests our help.
The best advice I have
for anybody working with Eagle candidates
is to take a good long look
at the applicable
section of the Guide to Advancement 2013,
the Eagle Application
and the Eagle Project Workbook.
once you have a working
knowledge of the process,
you'll better understand what your role is
and you can aid Scouts
in navigating their way through it.
The Eagle process to find in those documents
is actually very simple
and most of the verbiage
in the documents-
check them out and see if you agree with me-
is there to protect Scouts
from the kind of capricious, over anxious
interference that we sometimes see.
Now, unfortunately, I think
it grows to be a habit that
adults perform
really intensive reviews of
the paperwork and the Scouts
writing and stuff on
all of these forms and things
and they review it pretty intensively
and that leads to a lot of polishing
and expanding and rewriting
on the Scouts part. so
I guess if
a statement or
report actually written by the Scouts,
somehow slips through.
people are going to read it
and they might look at it and say,
well, this is insufficient
because no adults have been involved
in creating it. There's no
essay required for Eagle. What you're
referring to is called
a statement of ambitions and life
purpose in requirement 7
that accompanies the Eagle Application.
That requirement does not
define a certain length for
that statement or anything
that would indicate to me it could be judged
insufficient, let alone that
anyone's even really kind of permitted
to make that judgment. But anyway,
so far as the Scoutmasters
role in all this, well, my habit
of Scoutmaster was to review the workbook
briefly with the Scout
during his life Scoutmaster conference
and make sure he understood
what the project workbook
was so that he could get himself
rolling on beginning thinking
about an Eagle project.
Now, once a Scouts decided,
yeah, I'm going to be an Eagle Scout,
I'll do my best to offer help
and answer questions and make suggestions,
but 7 or 8 times out of 10
I leave well enough alone.
If he's told me he wants to be an Eagle Scout
and we go a couple months and there doesn't seem
to be any movement, you know, I'm going to ask him about it.
I'm going to encourage him,
I'm going to do what I can,
but the next time I get officially involved
as a Scoutmaster
is reviewing the project proposal
because it requires my signature,
I may look at it and we may
discuss what a proposal is,
what a plan is. you know
some notes about presenting it
to the troop committee
and what I found is that
many, many times Scouts have never
written a proposal
and they may need a little help
defining exactly how that works.
so after I've done that,
I really don't have an official
role until I end up at the Scoutmaster
conference for Eagle
and we talk about what his plans are
and what he'd like to do in his future.
usually by this time he's got
the application- the Eagle application-
in his hands and it's filled out.
he's written his statement.
but I rarely read the statements because
we're sitting there talking about it anyway
and I'd much rather talk to the Scout
about these things than read it off of a piece of paper.
I've had somewhere north
of 80 and south of 110
Eagle Scouts of Scoutmaster
and probably have read
maybe 10 or 15 statements because
the Scout asked my opinion of it.
in each case I kind of scan what
they write and say it looks good to me,
because in a lot of ways
it's really none of my business.
this is his work,
this is what he's sending forward,
and I can't ever recall
looking at a statement that I would have judged insufficient,
and then, basically,
my last official
in all this is shaking the Scout's hand
and handing him an Eagle badge.
anyone else involved with this process?
you know the advancement chair is going to get involved.
you can have a project coach,
you can do all kinds of things.
I think the Eagle process is
really very simple.
I think that it should be kept simple
and I think that people shouldn't get quite so anxious
about some of the things that they get anxious about.
and I'll say this,
and I think I've said it many times:
there's only one way for a Scout to reach Eagle:
completes all the requirements
right and then he successfully passes
a duly appointed Board of Review.
there's no Eagle Plus,
there's no Eagle Minus,
there's only Eagle. and everything else is kind of window dressing,
isn't it?
Eagle means something different to each Scout.
each one of them is an individual.
each one of them is different.
Jeff got back and said:
thanks for the response.
I do appreciate it.
I agree, the process can get a little overblown,
and you're right, I was referring to the statement
of ambitions and life purpose.
thanks for your advice and all your hard work
on the website and the podcast.
Brad Schroer is the
Scout Master, Troop 414
in Bedford, New Hampshire,
said I've listed quite a few of your podcasts.
thanks for all you do.
I've been moving our troop along
with some of your suggestions.
I know you're a proponent of the Scouts forming their own patrols,
but how does this work out for less
popular Scouts
when a patrol or a patrol leader
doesn't want a particular Scout in their patrol?
do you have any particular
ground rules set?
well, we've talked about this
in the past couple of podcasts.
the ground rules for everything that we do
are the Scout Oath and Law.
it's really the heart of the matter.
no other rules are required.
don't make other rules.
champion the Scout Oath and Law.
Scouts follow the Oath and Law.
Scouts aren't concerned with popularity,
serving their fellow Scouts.
so it's very difficult for me
to imagine, in a situation
where Scouts are following the Oath and Law,
that there's going to be a problem
with leaving people out when they form patrols.
now, boys,
that's a different story.
they need to think through what it means
to be a Scout. so when
the time comes to form patrols,
this is something that you want to point out
to your patrol leaders council.
so a boy says: I don't want to be in a patrol
with this other guy, he's a real pain.
well, my answer to something like that
would be:
maybe so,
and I understand, because people can be
a little bit of a pain sometimes.
but what part of the Scout Oath and Law
describes rejecting a fellow Scout
because, quote, he's a pain?
unquote.
every boy gets to be a Scout
and we accept him as he is
because we practice the Scout Oath
and Law.
there are friendships between boys
and that this is important.
but a Scout is a friend to every other Scout
and it doesn't necessarily mean
that that Scout is their favorite.
but if the Oath and Law mean anything at all,
no Scout
is certainly an enemy of any other Scout
and no Scout is deemed
unpopular.
now, I know just as you do, the boys sometimes
find it challenging to be Scouts.
so it's our responsibility
to champion the Oath and Law
that we do.
if you work at it, there's no questions about popularity.
there's no room for marginalizing any Scout
based on whether other
boys like him or not.
boys may do that kind of thing,
but Scouts never do.
Brad went on to ask: how often do
your patrols rearrange?
I think I remember you saying
on one of the podcasts it could be often
and at will. is that correct?
how many distractions does that cause?
well, Brad, our patrols get rearranged
when the patrol leaders council think
that it's needed.
that's the at will part that you hear me talk about.
the reset
of patrols is usually spurred by the election
a new senior patrol leader
and then he's appointing Scouts
to new positions of responsibility
and sometimes that makes resetting
the patrols
necessary. now, in my experience,
this causes pretty much zero distraction.
every once in a while
a Scout may want to shift from one patrol
to another.
they ask the senior patrol leader
and I like to be made aware of those situations
and give them a little advice.
what I like to do is discuss the importance
of patrol size related to function-
not too big, not too small,
and we've had happy patrols of four or five
active Scouts and equally happy patrols of eight
or ten. and overlaying all of this,
as I said before,
we talk about how the oath and law
informs these decisions, and usually
things come off without a hitch.
here's two questions from the same source
that asked to remain anonymous.
question number one:
I've been told as customary for Scoutmasters
to step down from their role
while their own son
serves as senior patrol leader,
which my son is currently doing.
is this a common practice? I'm unaware of.
I can remember sometime in the long,
dim, distant past of hearing this
somewhat obscure urban legend in Scouting.
but no, it's not a common practice.
if it was advisable
or customary, it would be mentioned in our
training or in the Scoutmaster Handbook
or the troop committee guidebook
or other resources that are provided to us.
and I would ask whoever advised
you to do that to point out where it's
advised or mandated in the literature,
because they won't find anything.
question number two:
a small faction of parents
would be creating havoc for our troop committee.
our district executive
and unit commissioner have been
in close contact with these parents,
but they did not communicate the concerns
that they had
to us in a timely manner, and that complicated
things further.
is this a common practice?
well, I really can't tell you
if that's a common practice or not, but I've seen it
before. it certainly seems to be
kind of a counterproductive way of handling things
I think anybody would rather hear about
any issues or problems being raised
right away, when
possibly they could do something about it,
rather than a couple of weeks or months
later. these kinds of storms
where parents get upset- maybe they talk to a
commissioner or a district executive.
these kind of things happen,
hopefully rarely.
I don't spend a whole lot of time
worrying about them myself.
I learned over years the hard way
because I know how upsetting it is when this happens.
if you just stick to your work
as a Scoutmaster focused on
delivering the program to your Scouts,
things gain a little perspective.
a lot of times storms like this come up
when there's been some fundamental organizational change,
like appointing a new Scoutmaster,
and if you look at it from
a positive perspective,
when people are questioning what's going on,
they're a good opportunity for a little introspection.
you know,
I ask what I'm doing and
why I'm doing it and if I've carried out
my responsibilities properly
and whether or not I need to change my practices
and attitudes. and when questions like this
have come up in the past,
they have certainly helped me do
just that. Another anonymous question:
our troop committee
recently discussed a Scout
who has been consistently spoken to
about his disruptive behavior
for the past six months.
at our last camping trip
he managed to bully two boys to the point
where he made them cry.
the Scoutmaster decided the Scout would be told
he was taking a month long time out
and the time that he had already served
in a position of responsibility
would not count towards
his next rank. The committee disagreed
with the Scoutmaster's judgment on this,
but the Scoutmaster replied
that this Scout was not living the oath
and law and that's part of our expectations.
I would appreciate your opinion
on this situation.
well, in my opinion,
informed by the Scoutmaster handbook
and training, in my experience
Scoutmaster's troops and committees, or anyone
other than the Scout's parents,
should never discipline or punish
Scouts, and this includes
a month long time out you describe
if a Scout is continually misbehaving-
and to me
continually is twice
doing the same thing- after I've discussed it
with him once,
I speak to his parents.
how we get six months into this
without anybody taking any definitive
action is part of the problem.
if I've had to speak to a Scout
about the same misbehavior
more than once, his parents are going to get involved
and I speak to the parents
and I tell them that
they need to address that at home because
we don't discipline or punish Scouts
and when they've taken whatever actions they consider
adequate, for however long they think they need
and can assure me
that this sort of behavior won't be repeated,
then, and only then,
can their Scout return to being active
with Scouts, and I go into this
in a little more depth in a post called
Constructive Scouting Discipline
and I'll link to that in the post that contains this
podcast. as for denying him
a tenure, he's accrued towards a rank requirement.
that is patently unfair.
the Guide to Advancement spells it out
very clearly in
Pencils Ready,
Section 4.2.3.4.5,
titled Win Responsibilities
Are Not Met.
it spells out very clearly that concerns about a Scout
fulfilling a position of responsibility
are addressed immediately,
not six months later,
not two months later.
the Scoutmaster suddenly decides that
none of this applies immediately
and that there's a clear understanding
of precisely what the problem is
and how it will be remedied.
it also states that denying
the Scout his tenure
retroactively is not fair.
so if you have a question
and you'd like to get in touch with me,
you're going to find out how to do that
in just a moment.
Music.
Thanks for listening to this
245th
edition of the Scoutmaster podcast.
here's how you can keep in touch.
read the blog at scoutmastercgcom
and, while you're there, you can subscribe
to receive updates to the blog by email.
you can join the 4,000
other mobile scouters who have the Scoutmaster
CG app on their mobile devices
and you can get the Scoutmaster
CG app at Google Play
or in the iTunes app store.
you can experience the wonders of
scoutmastercgcom through the vast
panorama of social media outlets.
join over 7,000 folks
who like Scoutmaster blog on Facebook.
tweet along with a chorus of
1,100 tweeters on Twitter.
pin the Pultritudinous pictures
proffered publicly with
1,800 other prolific
pinners on Pinterest
scoutmastercgcom.
or join the 400 odd folks
who form the exclusive
scoutmastercgcom
on Google Plus.
now, if none of that makes any sense to you,
if you can't face Facebook,
if Twitter makes you better,
if you have no interest in Pinterest,
if you don't put the yoyo on YouTube
and if you're a minus when it comes to Google Plus,
that's alright. Bunky,
zoom into the late 90s and send me an email
that's right
at clark
at scoutmastercgcom.
C-L-A-R-K-E
you know what comes next.
of course you know what comes next.
I say
the scoutmaster blog and the scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored
by the Boy Scouts of America,
or any other scouting organization for that matter,
because you know, it's just me.
I've got a microphone and a laptop.
I can get online,
I can publish a podcast.
that's right, it's only me,
and we do try to have a little bit of fun along the way.
and speaking of fun,
here's our founder, Sir Robert.
Good luck to you and good camping.
why? thank you, sir?
until next time, everyone.